bonjour mes chers amis à vous qui êtes
dans la seule les républicains et à tous
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur en train de
se restaurer mais qui nous écoute et
vous avez vu tout à l'heure en gala
merkel s'exprimer je voudrais juste vous
donner quelques chiffres le taux de
chômage des jeunes en allemagne il est à
peine 2 8% le taux de chômage des jeunes
en france
il atteint pratiquement 25% n'allons pas
dire que c'est de la faute de l'europe
regardons ce qu'avait dit le président
françois hollande à son congrès du
bourget il avait dit les jeunes seront
ma priorité
heureusement qu est ce que ça aurait été
si ça n'aurait pas été la priorité de
françois hollande
il s'est fixé il s'est fixé de limites
il a dit il nous faudra cinq cent mille
jeunes en apprentissage d'ici à 2017
mais la réalité c'est que nous avec
nicolas sarkozy nous avions créé un
militaire de l'apprentissage et de la
formation professionnelle notre objectif
c'était lui cent mille jeunes d'ici à
alors bienvenue chez les républicains
d'un nu chez les bâtisseurs parce que
les socialistes ont sondé démolisseurs
ils ont cassé l'apprentissage puisque
aujourd'hui c'est un recul massif
il n'aime pas le mérite il n'aime pas la
valeur travail
il n'aime pas la diversité des
intelligences ils n'aident pas à voir
des jeunes dans les métiers
la réalité c'est que nous nous
respectons tous les parcours
nous respectons toutes les intelligences
parce que nous avons nous croyons que
nous avons besoin de tous les talents au
service de la france dévient les
républicains et vive la france